>> Greg: THE NEW MAYOR THAT
HAS NO GUTS IS CERTIFIABLY NUTS.
CITIES RIFE WITH CRIME BUT DON'T
MESS WITH HER OFFICE TIME.
IT WAS CONFIRMED WHAT MANY OF US
HAD SUSPECTED ABOUT CHICAGO
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT.
SHE IS RAVING BONKERS.
EVEN JUSSIE SMOLLETT SAYS I FIND
HER HARD TO BELIEVE.
THE "CHICAGO TRIBUNE" OBTAINED
AN EMAIL SHE SENT TO A SCHEDULER
IN JANUARY IN WHICH SHE
COMPLAINS SHE WASN'T GETTING
ENOUGH OF WHAT SHE CALLED OFFICE
TIME.
EXCEPT LIGHTFOOT REPEATED
SEVERAL SENTENCES OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN LIKE A
PSYCHOPATH.
IT WAS SHOCKING WHEN PEOPLE
REPEAT THEMSELVES IN CHICAGO
IT'S USUALLY HELP, HELP, I'VE
BEEN SHOT.
I'VE BEEN SHOT.
RATHER THAN SUMMARIZE THE EMAIL
AND WE ARE NOT MAKING THIS CRAP
UP, WE ARE GOING TO REDO THE
WHOLE THING JUST TO SHOW YOU HOW
[BLEEP] THIS IS.
>> SINCE MY PRIOR REQUEST FOR
OFFICE TIME ARE ROUTINELY
IGNORED I'M RESORTING TO THIS.
I NEED OFFICE TIME EVERY DAY.
I NEED OFFICE, EVERY DAY.
NOT JUST ONCE A WEEK OR SUNDAYS
BUT EVERY DAY.
NOT JUST ONCE A WEEK OR SUNDAYS,
EVERY DAY.
NOT JUST ONCE A WEEK OR SUNDAYS
-- SOME DAYS, EVERY DAY.
BREAKS OR TRANSITIONS BETWEEN
MEETINGS ARE NOT OFFICE TIMES.
BREAKS OR TRANSITION TIMES
BETWEEN MEETINGS ARE NOT OFFICE
TIMES.
BREAKS OR TRANSITION TIMES
BETWEEN MEETINGS ARE NOT OFFICE
TIME.
IF THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
IMMEDIATELY I WILL START
UNILATERALLY CANCELING THINGS
EVERY DAY.
IF THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
IMMEDIATELY I WILL START
UNILATERALLY CANCELING THINGS
EVERY DAY.
IF THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
IMMEDIATELY I WILL START
UNILATERALLY CANCELING THINGS
EVERYDAY.
HAVE I MADE MY SELF CLEAR
FINALLY?
HAVE I MADE MYSELF CLEAR
>> Greg: WE HAD TO GET EMILY
TO DO THAT BECAUSE SHE IS THE
FASTEST TALKER ON THE PLANET.
ENDLESSLY REPEATING THE SAME
THING AS A SIGN OF MENTAL
INSTABILITY OR THAT YOU WORK FOR
CNN.
BUT I REPEAT MYSELF.
ON MONDAY SHE DEFENDED THE
EMAIL.
>> TO WRITE AN EMAIL LIKE THAT
COMES AFTER A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AND FRUSTRATION.
WE GOT BEYOND IT.
THE CHALLENGES THAT WERE AT THE
HEART OF THE EMAIL WRITTEN FIVE
PLUS MONTHS AGO.
I THINK WE ARE IN A BETTER
PLACE.
>> Greg: A BETTER PLACE.
ANYTHING IS BETTER THAN THAT
PLACE.
IMAGINE IF SHE EXPRESSES MUCH
FRUSTRATION ABOUT HER CITY'S
MURDER RATE AS SHE DOES ABOUT
HER OFFICE TIME.
IN THE INTEREST OF FAIRNESS,
HERE'S KAT READING ONE OF MY
EMAILS.
>> SINCE MY PRIOR REQUEST IS
ROUTINELY IGNORED.
KILMEADE IS A LIAR.
I DIDN'T LEAVE THAT IN THE
HOT TUB.
I HAVE BEEN CONSTIPATED FOR FIVE
DAYS.
I'VE BEEN CONSTIPATED FOR FIVE
HAVE I MADE MYSELF CLEAR
FINALLY?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WORKING FOR THE
CHICAGO MAYOR DOESN'T SEEM SO
BAD NOW DOES IT?
KAT DO I EVER DO WEIRD EMAILS?
>> Kat: YEAH.
I DON'T THINK WORKING ON THE
SHOW I'VE EVER GOTTEN AN EMAIL
THAT WASN'T VERY STRANGE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT ONE.
IT'S WEIRD.
IT'S AGGRESSIVE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT WAS
EFFECTIVE ALTHOUGH I THINK JUST
THE GENERAL FEAR THAT EMPLOYEES
HAVE OF HER PROBABLY IS.
ON THE LIST OF THINGS THAT I
DON'T LIKE ABOUT LORI LIGHTFOOT,
THIS IS PRETTY LOW ON THE LIST.
THE GENERAL WAY IN WHICH SHE
RUNS THE CITY IS PRETTY MUCH THE
WORST PART.
>> Greg: JAMES, THERE HAS TO
BE A CORRELATION BETWEEN HOW BAD
THE CITY IS AND WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE.
THAT EMAIL IS CRAZY.
>> James: OUT OF 3 MILLION
PEOPLE, SHE IS THE BEST PERSON
IN CHICAGO?
I THINK SHE NEEDS LESS OFFICE
TIME.
SHE'S AFRAID TO LEAVE HER OFFICE
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN THREE
MASS SHOOTINGS IN THE PAST WEEK.
HOW DO YOU --
AND SHE SAYS HER STAFF IS
BETTER.
HER STAFF FROM WHEN SHE WROTE
THAT EMAIL, THEY ARE ALL GONE.
OF COURSE IT'S BETTER NOW.
>> Greg: THEY ALL LEFT
SCREAMING FROM THE BUILDING.
>> James: SHE IS BY HERSELF
NOW.
>> Greg: SHE HAS HER ALONE
TIME.
TERENCE, HAVE YOU EVER SENT AN
EMAIL LIKE THIS?
>> Terrence: BETELGEUSE,
BETELGEUSE, BEETLEJUICE,
BEETLEJUICE.
YOU HAVE THE MAYOR FROM HELL
SITTING IN HER OFFICE WRITING
THE SAME SENTENCE OVER AND OVER
WHILE HER CITY IS TURNING INTO
GOTHAM.
>> James: SHE WROTE THAT EMAIL
DURING HER OFFICE TIME.
I HAVE SOMETHING FOR HER TO DO
SINCE SHE LIKES TO WRITE.
WRITE OUT ALL THE NAMES OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE GONE DOWN WEEKEND
AFTER WEEKEND IN CHICAGO.
START WITH A 7-YEAR-OLD START ID
KILLED.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
SUSAN.
>> Susan: I'M GLAD HE DOES THE
COMPANY SO I CAN BE SERIOUS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THAT WASN'T EVEN A
PERSONAL EMAIL.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT SHE DOES ON
HER PERSONAL EMAILS.
IT'S PRETTY SCARY.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS?
HAS STUART VARNEY EVER SENT
EMAILS LIKE THIS?
>> Susan: HE JUST YELLS AT ME
IN PERSON.
IN A CORPORATE WORLD, WOULDN'T
YOU BE FIRED?
IT'S LIKE TOM CRUISE SCREAMING
AT THE CREW.
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IN A BANK OR INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS.
SHE CAN'T BE COMPETENT.
YOUR POINT, HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
THIS IS A GRE